for STELARA®.
>> Laura: CONTRARY TO WHAT
ENRIQUE JUST SAID, WE DO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH QUIETLY RELOCATING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ALL AROUND
THE COUNTRY RIGHT HEAR,       HI
THE COUNTRY RIGHT HEAR,       HN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
FOR DETAILS OF HOW THESE
IMMIGRATION POLICIES AFFECT YOU
AND YOUR COMMUNITY, WE TURN TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE NORTHERN
AND I HAD TO BRING IT ON TV
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO A
PREVIOUSLY SAFE COMMUNITY OF
MIDDLE-CLASS, UPPER MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE IN NORTHERN VIRGINIA.
>> OBVIOUSLY GANG ACTIVITY HAS
INCREASED VIOLENCE AND CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY IN THE NORTHERN
VIRGINIA NEIGHBORHOODS.
YOU KNOW, THEY SHOW THIS IMAGE
OF POWER AND RESPECT, BUT IN
REALITY, IT'S NOT POWER AND
RESPECT.
>> Laura: WHAT OTHER TACTICS?
WHAT ARE THEY DO?
>> THEIR TACTICS ARE ABOUT
HAVING RESPECT.
IF YOU DON'T RESPECT THEM, THEN
THEY ARE GOING TO RETALIATE WITH
VIOLENCE, AND IT'S GOING TO BE
PRETTY COOL VIOLENCE.
>> THEY GO AFTER KIDS,
ESPECIALLY KIDS FROM LATINO
COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS THAT WERE
BROUGHT HERE.
THEY ARE BEING SENT A VERY BE
VIA COMMERCIAL AIRLINES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO SPONSORS
PAID A LOT OF THE SPONSORS
THEMSELVES ARE ILLEGAL
AND THE KIDS ARE IN A NEW PLACE.
I FEEL TERRIBLE FOR THE KIDS.
THEY DON'T SPEAK THE LANGUAGE
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE ILLITERATE
IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE.
THEY COME HERE AND THESE PEOPLE
ARE LIKE I'LL BE YOUR FRIEND,
I'LL BE YOUR FATHER, AND
SUDDENLY THEY ARE IN IT.
>> THEY ARE VERY VULNERABLE IN
THE GANGS KNOW IT.
THEY EXPLOIT THAT AND THEIR LACK
OF FAMILY STRUCTURE, THE
RELATIONSHIP ISSUES, EVERYTHING.
>> SEE WHAT I READ RECENTLY
ABOUT DECAPITATIONS.
SOME OF THESE ARE REPORTED AND
THAT SOME OF THEM ARE NOT.
DECAPITATIONS, MANASSAS,
VIRGINIA, IS A QUIET COMMUNITY
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT'S LIKE A DIFFERENT PLACE NOW.
>> THE ACTIVITY AND GANGS HAVE
CRIMES THAT THEY ARE CARRYING
OUT NOW IS MUCH WORSE THAN IT
WAS 20 YEARS AGO WHEN WE FIRST
SAW THE GANGS EMERGING.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT JUST MS-13.
THIS FLORENCIA-1300 LATIN KINGS,
L.A., CHICAGO HAS THESE
PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE HERE NOW.
IT'S AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT BASED
AGAIN, WHAT YOU DO?
YOU FIND THEM AND TRY TO DEPORT
THEM, BUT IT TAKES A LONG TIME
AND A LOT OF YOUR MANPOWER.
WE HAVE TO HAVE PROGRAMS THAT
INTERVENE AND PREVENT THESE KIDS
THE PLATFORM THAT WE WORK OFF OF
HIS ENFORCEMENT AND INTERVENTION
PREVENTION AND EDUCATION.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE BOTH, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Laura: WE HAVE SO MUCH
EXTRA MONEY TO BE SPENDING AND
THAT TO OUR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IT IS SHOCKING.
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU ARE
DOING.
SOME NEWSPAPERS ARE BETTER THAN
OTHERS AT REPORTING AND ACTUALLY
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS DONE A
MANASSAS AND ARLINGTON,